je ministre bonjour mais c'est vrai avec
nous bonjour daniel très plaisir d'être
ici première fête du canada en tant que
ministre votre première fête du canal
est pas comme ça que vous l'aviez pas du
tout non ça rien à voir avec le format
des habituels non tout à fait déjà il y
avait un certain niveau difficulté des
gros travaux sur la colline donc il
fallait commencer à penser à s'adapter
un peu mais là est arrivée la crise du
duc à vide et le tout les plantules
quand il faut lui en fallu vraiment
recommencer presqu'à presque à zéro
très rapidement est-ce que c'est pas des
miller va changer d'après vous la façon
dont vous allez travailler dans votre
ministère travaillait pour un butin oui
à quoi la la est-ce qu'on va revenir à
la normale ou à quoi cette normalité
elle va pouvoir ressembler dans un an
c'est à dire mais certainement pour un
teint je pense que tout à fait il faut
il faut changer nos façons de voir les
choses de les penser et plus précisément
dans le code événements comme la fête du
canada de les organiser est ce que ça
pourrait vouloir dire une nouvelle façon
de faire dans l'avenir ou une occasion
peut-être de réinventer votre façon de
présenter
ou de financer ou de mettre à l'avant
plan
certains éléments de la culture
canadienne je pense qu'il a présentement
une réflexion une discussion au sein de
la société culturelle artistique
canadienne de dire est ce que il ya une
crise
est-ce que c'est pas l'opportunité de
voir d'autres modèles de faire les
choses que l'on fait depuis un certain
temps moi je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ça ils nous allons essayer d'être
un partenaire et d'encourager sa tout en
un comprenant bien que quand on parle
des arts vivants par exemple c'est pas
vrai qu'on va tout pouvoir faire sur le
virtuel ou sur le numérique
qu'est ce que vous espérez que les
canadiens retirent de cette fête du
canada qui sera ma foi tout à fait
inhabituel si daniel bélanger dans son
album rêver mieux qu'ils disent est ce
le monde tout seul ensemble mais je
pense que on va on va je souhaite qu'on
se rappelle de cette fête du canal comme
étant celle où on s'est dit après
plusieurs mois d'une crise qui était
difficile pour beaucoup de gens à
travers le pays et la planète dit encore
et encore qui est encore difficile tout
à fait on a réussi a malgré tout à
trouver ce moment là pour pour se
rassembler tout en gardant nos distances
en le faisant de façon virtuelle mais en
se rappelant c'est quoi c'est quoi être
canadien c'est quoi ce rêve là cette
aspiration là que nous avons d'être
canadiens canadiennes
qu'est ce qu'on a accompli piqué ce qui
reste à faire devant je pense que c'est
un moment c'est un moment pour célébrer
puis peut-être aussi pour faire un peu
d'introspection
ici on réussit à faire ça si on réussit
après après le 1er juil aps les gens
c'est finalement on aimait ça ce
téléphone puis où on a réfléchi un peu
on a célébré
je pense qu'on aura on aura réussi l'an
prochain est ce qu'on fait une fête du
canada virtuel encore enfin ça town
c'est une bonne question
on va commencer à travailler sur des
plans qu'on sera évidemment prêts à
mettre au recyclage au besoin si si les
choses changent encore alors on aura
probablement est plein
un 'plan b' pour pour l'an prochain
sylvain gilbert ministre du patrimoine
bonne fête du canal merci beaucoup
daniel à vous aussi